il était une fois
son plaisir l'entrée
joli faire on dirait qu'on a un mouton
noir dans le troupeau de l'état de robes
on va l'appeler blackie la vie je te
présente cadeaux
est ce que c'est bien toi nous avons été
sélectionnés parmi des centaines de
milliers de chiens pour devenir
astronaute
mais il ya eu un problème cette fois ça
y est le pied sur la lune
je suis châle ou à ces blacks et et tout
ça c'est la faute de canaux d'eau et sa
vie en danger
sylvain paquin on te suit jet ski pour
la gagne alors que le but lui mais tout
le monde
k
comment
là on a un vrai chien de garde ou we can
tho on n'en a plus besoin arrête surtout
le touchant